more dire economic warnings for
president biden inflation keep surging
prices just jumped five percent that is
the fastest pace since 2008.
and you know all those unemployment
benefits that the government has been
just dishing out
a new report says criminals have stolen
about half of all that money
since the pandemic started it adds up to
almost
400 billion dollars most of it going to
crime syndicates
in china and russia this
is bad news but almost completely
unsurprising that that much cash that
goes out the door that quickly
uh without any safeguards is then taken
over
using ransomware and other dark web
techniques by these criminal gangs i
think this is an absolute travesty this
is a
breach of the public trust and i know
people i know well
i know one woman in particular in new
jersey was laid off in january
she has yet to be able to get through to
the unemployment office
and she's living at home now she's
trying to get she wants to work she's
trying to
get a job make things happen and you
cannot figure out a way
to get the unemployment office to call
you back but criminals can figure out a
way
to get that money and meantime we have
the fbi figuring out
how to get the blockchain money back
from the colonial pipeline ransom
payment
and i think that the government should
not be allowed to do
any more of these big massive payments
without some new mechanism
to get the money to people in a more
honest fashion yes so that it can't be
stole i mean
the chinese the russians have our money
that was supposed to go to people who
really needed it during a pandemic
that's an
outrage yeah people who were laid off
people who couldn't work because their
their kids
are not in school and then you have ppp
loans right
that were also subject to massive fraud
and corruption
uh just one of many reasons why there
are so many people out there who do not
trust the federal government
that's very libertarian of you and i'm
going to half agree at this particular
moment i would love
to know because i don't think any of us
here would deny that people needed help
right businesses individuals right a
hundred percent which is jesse didn't
like it
i think people need to just do what they
can on their own
i'm just kidding nicely done the home
studio was great
anywho so i would love to hear i mean
obviously 400 billion is a ton of money
and the fact that it went to russian and
chinese actors
makes it even worse so what can we do
looking forward to ensure that this
doesn't happen
i know people who got checks who
shouldn't have gotten checks i know
people who should have gotten checks who
didn't get those checks
and we need obviously accountability for
this and hopefully it'll be raised
um with putin and there'll be
conversations with the chinese about
this because
i mean it's just straight-up theft well
this is what happens when the government
is too big
it's it's big it's powerful there are no
more checks and balances when it's that
much
of a behemoth jesse yeah this country's
so rich 400 and
bill can walk out the door no one even
blinks an eye
it's on trump and biden they're both
accountable for it
dana said it best it's a breach of the
public trust
it's a disrespect to the taxpayers of
this country
you throw money out there and there's no
safeguards there's no mechanism to
prevent fraud
to have accountability and where's nancy
she's in control of the purse strings
she hasn't said a word about this she's
the speaker of the house she controls
where all this money goes she hasn't
said anything about it it's like she
doesn't even
care because she doesn't remember how
she fought tooth and nail
to deny trump two billion well 400
billion just went out the door
and she's silent stone cold silent it's
terrible yeah good luck getting that
back
inflation though greg this is something
that is going to hit
lower and middle income earners more
than repealing the 2017
tax cuts because they're going to be
more for every drink yes
like something that shrinks when it's
that i can't
say you keep bringing up russia and and
chinese agents
i mean actors what about our actors
that they can't even work restaurants
because they're closed
wait tables anyway you want your head to
explode
yes do you want your head to explode
remember
that joe biden appointed the person to
oversee these payments
who had the same job in washington state
during which almost a bill i think it
was almost a billion dollars
were stolen and who were they stolen by
nigerians so we have people in
government
who got defrauded by nigerian scammers
i know grandmothers who aren't getting
defrauded by nigerian scammers and
princes
right this is insane i mean like that
the fact that this person
was able to fail up and you're right
it's an abuse to the taxpayer
i don't think democrats no offense
jessica value
money uh as as a bureaucrat that's about
my bitcoin strategy yeah
exactly so no because democrats don't
see money
they just see what they just see other
people's money and it's not theirs it's
like they're driving by a car accident
and they go
that's not me and that's what they're
doing they're driving by a billion
dollars here a billion dollars there
it's not really
money because it's not mine that's that
is the take home
and it's infuriating but think about who
he hired yeah who was that you actually
researched for this segment i'm proud of
you i actually brought this up about two
months ago on this very show
from washington state i don't remember
her name who is somebody in the uh
room johnny uh johnny get back together
woman's name from washington
yes also california california has the
same problem
right i don't know her name either it's
probably kamala harris
yes if it's a california politician
problem i'm just saying
all right coming up hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else